hello and welcome to another adventure
style video this time i'll be working
through simulating a real robot and
attempting to train and learn certain
actions in a simulator and then
transferring that to reality but if you
have a real programmable robot why would
you ever need a simulator
programming simple actions like a jump
that i worked on here can take an hour
or more of r d as you battle battery
life trial and error you often also need
to rig something up so that you can
safely and easily do that rnd and
overall the process can just be somewhat
tedious and painful the simulators that
people use range from everything from
like 3d graphs to
complex physics and ray tracing capable
simulators when you're trying to model
something that's going to be heavily
physics based like four-legged robots or
even heavily visually based with cameras
or maybe lidar and other ultrasonic
sensors stuff like that it starts to
make sense to want something fairly
advanced and as close to reality as
possible at this point i've only ever
heard of nvidia's omniverse and the sims
that you can use within it but it sounds
pretty interesting and along the lines
of what i'm after so that's going to be
my first stop other than the simulator
we need something that describes the
robot to the simulator now i don't know
much about simulating robotics at this
point but i have learned fairly quickly
that people tend to use urdf files which
stands for universal robotic description
format there are other types of files
but urdf seems to be the most useful
unfortunately for this first quadruped
that i have there are no pre-made urdf
files and i have no idea how to make one
that said the urdf file that we're
looking at right now is part of a robot
called biddle and it just so happens
that one of these showed up on my
doorstep you can buy the biddle pre-made
or you can put it together and i opted
to put mine together just to learn more
about it for those who are curious it's
a 250 dollar quadruped robot i'll put a
link to it in the description
after installing omniverse i'll grab
isaac's sim from the exchange tab wait
for that to install and then launch it
from the library tab startup takes a
minute but then we get this sort of
blank sim canvas and i want to bring in
the uidf for the biddle robot for that i
have the repository here from what i can
understand i need to place this urdf in
its own directory which i'll just call
urdf the reason for this is inside the
actual biddle.urdf file we can see that
it wants to find the meshes by going
first backwards a directory then it's
going to look for the meshes folder
which will contain the objects directory
for that same reason i'll also create a
meshes directory for the obj or object
directory at this point i honestly have
no idea what the heck joint monkey is
but i'll probably figure that out later
let's go ahead and get this into the sim
next we can go to the import here we
have various options we could actually
place the files inside of omniverse or
we could load them from anywhere on the
pc and so on
i have these folders on the desktop so
i'll go ahead and just import them there
following some steps that i found from a
tutorial on nvidia we'll uncheck the fix
base link since the robot moves around
it's not fixed and then we can lower the
joint drive strength to 1000 and then
click import to import the actual robot
to the stage
it seems to me that things are paused
initially but if you hover over the sim
window you can actually start the
physics simulation by hitting play
but right now there's really nothing
else here so the robot just falls into
the abyss
so the next thing that we can add here
is a ground plane i'll hit stop again
and then go create physics and then
choose ground plane then i can move the
ground plane up and down a bit and then
hit play
next to actually move things around on
the biddle robot we can go to the stage
tab and search for joints then picking
one of the joints we can head down to
drive and we can move around the target
position which subsequently will move
that joint to that target position and
actually move the robot in the simulator
and this is cool it looks really nice
but i really want to do this via code
not manually like this through some
poking around i did find you could go to
like window in script editor and this
appears to be a python editor but i
couldn't really find any great
information on how to do this or how to
plug into the sim
via python so returning back to that
github where i found the original urdf
file for the biddle robot it's time to
inspect jointmonkey.pi here i see isaac
jim as a package but what is this i
don't see it anywhere on pip
through an internet search i do find the
following page i'm not really sure how
isaac jim relates to isaac sim who's
isaac we don't know all mysteries so
i'll hit join here it does appear to be
instant at least at the time of my going
through this the download is a tar.gz i
can extract this and essentially there's
a readme that points to an html file
that helps you to get started with
everything once everything is set up i
can run the jointmonkey.pi which is the
one that actually came with the package
and things are starting to make sense
now so the github suggested that we go
into the assets directory create a new
directory called meshes and place
objects within there after doing that we
want to place the biddle urdf file into
the urdf directory then we want to
replace the jointmonkey.pi that came
with the examples with the one from this
repository i'll just copy and paste it
over and save finally we want to run the
joint monkey and choose asset id 7. so
going back into the python examples
opening up a terminal and running joint
monkey with id 7 we can see that we have
the bitter robots articulating their
joints now i finally feel like i'm onto
something but these bittles are just
floating there they're not being
impacted in any way by physics and
that's really what i'm after checking
some of these other examples i'm fairly
confident that 1080 balls of solitude is
going to at least have some gravity
involved since in a physics simulator a
ball would be very boring if it didn't
have gravity
sure enough it does indeed appear that
these balls are affected by gravity
now when i pull up these two scripts and
kind of look through them i don't see
anything here immediately i know it's
here i'm 100 confident there's something
here
but i don't see
what it is about this that is different
than joint monkey that is bringing in
the physics so then of course the next
thing i wonder is what if we come down
to ball.urdf and replace that with
biddle.urdf so let's save that and run
that
and uh yeah that looks like it worked i
think i'm gonna call this the biddle
bomb so gravity and other physics is
definitely working here i see legs
bending and stuff when they hit the
ground or run into each other so this is
even more so we are on the right track
here
checking the files again i notice line
91 in jointmonkey.pi where fix baselink
is set to true and that is surely our
problem changing that to false and
running things i can see that was indeed
the issue after this i've created a
simplified script to just simply load in
the robot and do nothing more there's
really nothing special going on here
but after running this there's some
strange sliding going on i've only set
starting positions for the robot here
i'm not actually issuing any further
commands but yet it's just sliding so
then i play with various settings like
friction and stuff like that and i am
able to slow the sliding down slightly
but it's still happening and i'm fairly
confident that the settings that i am
going with to slow things down will also
negatively impact physics down the line
then i find that if i leave friction
high and move the limbs around
essentially to cause drag
i can slow down or even stop the sliding
but i'm unable to determine how to
reasonably handle for this and i know
something is still just wrong here
since it seemed like the sliding was the
worst on the balls of the feet i wanted
to see if this was happening in the
isaac sim instead of the gym once you've
created the scene that you want in the
sim you can save it as this usd file
which is universal scene description
which contains information for
everything including your bot the lights
ground plane and other objects and so on
since the urdf loads with the biddle on
its joints in a sort of kneeling
position rather than the feet i went
ahead and manually adjusted it so it
would be on its feet after doing that
and then running the simulation biddle
clearly isn't sliding anywhere anymore i
asked the people at nvidia who work on
omniverse and gym why the sliding was
happening in gym but wasn't hearing
anything back so i started to wonder
again about just simply using isaac's
sim instead of jim because it didn't
appear to be happening there which was
weird because i'm pretty sure i've read
that the underlying physics is actually
the exact same in jim and sim but
i don't think that's true i mean just
what i'm seeing looks like the physics
is much better in the sim but the
problem is i still struggled with
finding examples in clear documentation
to do even the most basic of things in
isaac's sim
the online available documentation is
extensive but it's not super clear for a
newcomer in my opinion with things like
how to just load in a scene or a urdf or
even how to import the omni package that
you see in various examples that said
i'm very guilty of being a high speed
skimmer and not a very good rtfmer and
i'm sure i'm just simply missing
something super obvious here so i
started going back through the
documentation and videos and stuff like
that
as i was re-watching one of the isaac
sim videos i noticed the terminal
location of one of the presenters which
was here in a hidden directory and in
here we have our own version of python
which also has the omni package it also
has a very juicy looking python samples
directory
inside of there it even has a
simple directory
now that is my style here there are
exactly what i was looking for examples
of loading a urdf loading an entire
scene and articulating a simple robot
this is exactly what i needed and what i
was looking for i'm not sure how i
missed this so i started off by loading
my biddle scene
and that's not quite what i was hoping
to see i'm honestly a little confused
and heartbroken here but still very
determined to figure this out
initially i thought i forgot the joint
drive strength set to 100 000 or
something like that but instead i found
that even after importing if i select
the joint and head down to the drive
section it's actually set to 10 000
despite setting the drive strength to
1000 on the import i'm not actually sure
what a joint's drive force is versus its
strength maybe these are the same maybe
they're different
and i don't even see a strength setting
here but i decided to set this to a
thousand for all eight joints and see if
that made a difference
next i want to use python to articulate
the joints so i copy the franca
articulation script call it biddle art
and edit it the first change is to load
the middle usd instead of the franco one
now i don't quite understand line 41
here what is this forward slash panda
and what would it be for biddle i
decided to load the sim manually find
the francobot and then search the stage
for the francobot for panda it appears
to me that panda is just where the
joints are located i don't really know
anything about this robot so i'm just
kind of guessing here i don't know why
it's called panda so then i load the
biddle next and search for my joints and
i see that their paths are in forward
slash biddle
so i presume that this is probably what
i want to use here coming back to the
script i go ahead and change that run
things and while waiting i noticed that
we're almost certainly going to fail
because the panda joint 2 is not going
to exist here and we want to use one of
our joint names
i'll go with left back shoulder joint
and increase these ranges so we have
more frames to actually see things
happen and set the target to negative
1.1 since i think the max range was
something just barely over one like
negative one to one or something like
that so things load in a bit spicy
i think this is just because the robot
still moves all legs from that kneeling
base starting position to the standing
position as quickly as possible but then
we get the lamest and yet most exciting
part of this entire process for me i've
loaded in a scene and i've moved the
robot all with python and this is
actually huge now i'd like to do some
basic r d to determine movement
information along with at what speed
should we attempt to move these joints
in order to do this it'd be really
inconvenient to start and restart the
sim every single time i've been cutting
out the loading times in the video but
it's more than a minute each time and
it's going to be best if we can just
leave the sim up and running for this
i've made a new script called manual
control inside i've just got some simple
code that creates a vector of values and
then saves those values to a numpy file
this vector is just ordered in the same
order of joints in the urdf and the
values will be used for the joint
position in the biddleart.pi file's main
loop so i'll run the manual script just
once so it will actually create a
position vector file and then i'll head
over to the biddleart file first i'll
set that second loop to be a while true
loop instead of ending after some
arbitrary frame count then what i want
to do is actually load in the position
vector but we'll go ahead and do this in
a try and accept since it's totally
possible that we'll try to read from
this file while it's being written and
will hit some sort of error then i'll
move the actual update outside of this
try and accept next i want to iterate
through every joint and set that joint's
position for this i'll create a list
that is the text name for that joint
since that's how we're going to actually
find it in the omni package here and
we'll make this list in the exact same
order as the position vector's values
i'll then iterate over the zip to joints
and position vector and we'll find the
articulation off by the joint's name j
and then the position target will be
that position from the file running that
while waiting for things to start i've
realized i have not imported numpy yet
and
i'm going to need to do that so i'll
just import numpy and then try to stop
the loading here then i go ahead and
rerun
and of course i never actually saved
after importing number awesome saving
and running again things look so far so
good let's try actually adjusting
something
and finally
it's working
so now what i want to do is hunt for
some settings for just a regular
standing position for example
it seems to me that omniverse and isaac
sim have a ton of features that i don't
even know about and a lot of stuff is
open and kind of just up to you to
figure out how to best do it so i'm sure
there are better ways to control the
robot than what i'm doing here but i'm
very happy with this and now i think
it's time to at least attempt to produce
a jump
in order to do that we really just need
to know the target positions for all of
the legs and then just tell biddle to go
to those positions
later there will likely be way more
complex moves and very specific motions
that we want to do but i think this is
like a good start to just kind of test
these this dynamic here another thing we
need to think about is how fast do we
want to go to some position and how to
stop ourselves from flying around
unintentionally this is true both in the
sim and in reality in the sim we can
probably have more force than would ever
be even possible via these servo motors
but even in real life if you move too
quickly you could fall over and so on so
i'll start by creating a new file called
jump dot pi to try to solve this
to begin i think the way to do this is
to just have a starting vector wherever
we are and then we have a target vector
where we want to be then we'll have a
variable to determine how fast we can
actually get there which will just be an
increment per step in this case again
i'm sure there's a better ways to do
this this is just what i've thought of
for now so then i'll iterate through the
current position and target positions
per each unit in the position vectors
i'll calculate the difference between
these then i'm going to want to modify
the position vector which will later
feed to the simulator as i iterate over
the current position vector so i'll make
a deep copy of the current vector i'll
also be using the index value of the
positions to make edits so i'll add in
an enumerate around the zip and make
c-paws and t-paws a tuple i wasn't
actually sure this syntax was going to
be valid i don't think i've ever done
that before so i tested it to confirm
and it still worked that's pretty cool
if the absolute value of the difference
is greater than the increment then we
want this position to move only by the
sign of the increment and not the full
amount otherwise if it's not too large
then we can move by the full target
difference let's loop through this 5
times to start and don't forget to save
to the new vector at the end and load
the current vector every time using this
for control might very well turn out to
be too sloppy slow and unreliably timed
for an actual robot or even the
simulated one for control and i
acknowledge that this method of
communicating with the simulator live
will probably need to change later but
communicating with the simulator live is
almost certainly going to be required
like this but for now let's just try to
solve one thing at a time and right now
this seems to be working okay running
this it does appear to be working as
expected let's view the sim at the same
time and yeah looking good there we'll
add a sleep and then also reset to our
original starting position and now i'll
make the iteration range a bit larger
than change the target vector a bit to
see it in action
it's a little jittery but it's working
pretty well
i think the jitteriness is probably
actually the fault of the reading and
writing of this numpy file as mentioned
earlier because i think it would
otherwise be at least a smooth motion
but that's just a guess
tinkering with different increment
speeds also appears to be working as
expected so then i develop some preset
vector positions like stand crouch tall
and so on then i'll make a move function
which takes a target vector and
increment as parameters
now to jump we can just simply crouch
and then stand tall very fast
and
well that sort of worked the nice thing
about a simulator is no parts were
damaged here
while the bot is upside down i take
advantage and try to come up with a
superior position so we don't flip this
time note that i'm pretty sure we can
also bind key presses to trigger certain
events so we could probably bind
something to do a reset or even a reset
with a fixed base so if we wanted to dev
positions like this we could do that
probably pretty easily i just don't know
exactly how to do that yet
as i prepare some new positions i have
to reset the simulator to test them and
somewhat comically on load i can't help
but notice that biddle jumps pretty well
here this is happening because the stage
loads in as a preset neil since that's
how the urdf is and then it is
immediately reading that position file
which is asking for a stand so biddle
goes as fast as possible to the new
position and this causes the jump
i still want to test the new positions
that i came up with and at least this
time it doesn't flip but ironically
enough the accidental jump is actually
better than what i've just come up with
so i know that the accidental jump
started off with all joints at zero
which is this sort of kneeling position
so i'll go ahead and just set up a
vector with those values i test this
just the kneel to make sure that it
works and that looks good to me
so then i add in a move to the tall
position at a fast pace essentially as
fast as possible and look at that it
worked
let's try that one more time
beautiful
and with that i think we're at a good
pausing point the next objective for me
is going to be to walk or do some other
complex method
but i don't want to do this manually i
want to use machine learning to at least
walk or do something else in the
simulator and if i can figure that out
then i want to attempt to use the same
machine learning model in the actual
biddle robot to do this we have quite a
few hurdles to overcome but i have a few
ideas on how i want to do that and we'll
see how that goes i'm sure it'll be
super smooth if you are interested in
machine learning and specifically deep
learning then check out the neural
networks from scratch book by myself and
daniel kukewa there we break down all of
the concepts of dense neural networks
into massive detail writing essentially
an entire deep learning framework from
scratch in python so as to get an
understanding of how neural networks
actually work if you're looking to
understand things with deep learning
past just simply calling functions this
is definitely a book for you you can buy
the ebook softcover or hardcover book at
nnfs.io and the softcover and hardcover
come with the ebook version thanks for
watching everyone and i'll see you in
another video
you